I have nothing else to prove I feel like
the greatest performer that I could have
been and people who love me feel that I
was the greatest performer they'd ever
seen so there's nothing left to prove
like that and this image is from
Prince's last concert less than a week
ago in his hometown of Minneapolis in a
poignant moment where he seemed to
reference his hospital stay
he told fans wait a few days before you
waste any prayers here's the thing about
Prince he was part of the fabric of
popular culture
he played himself a new girl anything
beautiful is worth getting hurt for oh
very well but I never said that No
me there's a core audience out there
that is never really going to go away
and you know this is my job this is what
I do you kind of stuck with me
principles beloved here at et in 2006 he
performed at our post Emmy party it was
a rooftop event on the Sunset Strip in a
magical night and who could ever forget
this performance the following year
despite a wind and rain storm Prince
rocked the Superbowl in 2007 I never
meant to cause a lot of people still
call it the best halftime performance
ever
prince cast his magical musical spell
again in 2014 she zombies man
he was a solo guest on the relaunched
Arsenio Hall Show and we caught just a
glimpse of the man behind the music
I can cook only one thing oh what's the
big French dish oh prince was funny a
musical genius and he got the sense he
knew he was on an amazing journey I
could quit now and call him today and
say I want to wonder and move on to the
next thing